hello CNM it's me again and I'm here
with the panel we have today Israeli
anchors back with his newest history
co-chair of the forward political party
Andrew Yang and Michigan congresswoman
soon to be Senator representative
Elizabeth
okay
uh should there be the first question
very brief should there be a primary for
vice president
oh then we're going back to the
beginning of the Republic when we were
on at the beginning didn't the vice
president wasn't a dude who ran with the
guy right whoever came in second place
second place can you imagine yeah
yeah but I I said during the show that I
thought that there should be a
competitive Primary in the Democratic
party which I do but if Joe were to run
again I think there should be a primary
for who is running mate should be
because the the fact is that person
could wind up stepping into his shoes
and the people should have a say
you're down with that no I have you
don't care
it's not gonna happen it's not gonna
happen right why waste political job I
don't think it should be primary floor
because I think that is as a candidate
that's your first choice as a possible
president and that shows a lot
yeah so you're with him or yeah no I
don't I don't think so it's the first
choice of the of the upcoming president
uh okay what does the panel think of the
new upgrades to chat GPT oh you must
many now this is not just Chachi BT is
very recent itself and now they found a
way to make something that we all find
creepy even creepier
is there any benefit to this technology
getting more advanced
uh well it can read college essays in
about 30 seconds so if that's too slow
for you then you can just turn it up and
then they can get it done in 10 or 15
seconds
um in all seriousness I have friends who
run firms and they're saying to me in
private look uh I'm going to let go of
40 of my staff because I can now get
more done with fewer people that's
happening to a lot of repetitive White
Collar jobs 44 of U.S jobs are either
repetitive manual or repetitive
cognitive and it turns out the
repetitive cognitive might be the first
to go
yeah but this is also at a moment when
we cannot get enough people to work in
the jobs that we have so while we may be
trending in that direction we have a
massive problem getting our current jobs
filled so I don't feel like we're out
you're right a list they're both
happening at the same time the fact is
the labor force has shrunk in by two and
a half million American workers
postcovid now they're at home we're
trying to get them back into the
workforce and then simultaneously this
Tech's going to come in and wipe out
let's say as one example two million
Americans work in call centers right now
making 17 bucks an hour like how long do
you think that'll last
I I don't know you're the expert
yeah that job is is probably an
automatable today I just read the
questions
um
was the online criticism of musician
Thames extravagant Oscar dress was
obstructed the view of audio oh I saw
that picture which obstructed the view
of audience members fair if you didn't
see this yes somebody had on a big white
ruffled thing in the they're all like
five people behind her were like
because uh what do you think I feel like
the actress should probably answer that
yeah yeah I haven't acted in years
listen it was a little extreme but I
don't think it calls for an overtime
question there are bigger things in life
that we can deal with right now thank
you
I thought it was not right
[Music]
something they know you're going to be
in an audience and you know there could
be people behind you I think we don't
think about accessible like she should
have been able to do what she wants when
she comes on the carpet and he collapse
that thing down and put it let's hear
the whole thing it's just like my sense
is also my sense is also the stylist
knew that we'll be talking about it so
that was it was intense oh yeah exactly
again you fell into the Trap I'm just
reading
this is what this game show is I just
read the questions from the people it's
so interesting you know what the people
are thinking of what they want right and
that is important no I can this is for
you how can people distinguish between
legitimate criticism of Israel and
anti-Semitism good question great
question great question
um okay so uh anti-zionism is
anti-Semitism first of all let's get
there thank you so much thank you
and I'll tell you what the difference is
there's nothing wrong with criticizing
Israeli government I just did that on
the show I think that the overhaul the
Judiciary overhaul is Extreme so it's
nothing there's nothing wrong with
criticizing Israeli government's
policies politicians that West Bank
whatever it is that you want if you have
uh something against if you're trying to
dismantle the Jewish state if you're
trying to go against the existence of
the state of Israel that's where the
line and draw is drawn and sadly there
are a lot of people that are criticizing
Israel and that's totally fine but there
are a lot of people that are saying that
Israel is not a legitimate country and
that is unacceptable okay
you agree
on the other side of the coin I don't
think it's anti-Semitism if you care
deeply about the state of the
Palestinian Affairs I mean if you care
about people that's not anti-Semitism or
if you care I mean and I think that
sometimes people go too far and they say
any criticism of Israel is anti-Semitism
every concern about the Palestinians is
anti-Semitism and that's also BS a
hundred percent uh
[Applause]
politicians there's no political
uh
Utah Governor Spencer Cox will sign a
bill that bends abortion clinics across
the state by the end of the year is
abortion under threat Nationwide well
done I mean yes I'm going to say a big
yes but this is so this is actually
closing yeah I mean well and also this
week I see there's a federal judge in
Texas who is looking to somehow rig it
so that you can't get the abortion pill
medication yeah not just in Texas but
Nationwide I don't even understand how
that would work but the fact that
they're trying it is a little scary yeah
I I just I think we should all be very
very clear that the right to have an
abortion in the United States is deeply
deeply under threat they overturned Roe
already and already in 32 states in the
in the country it's very very hard if
not impossible to get an abortion and
the constant Onslaught now on medication
so that even in a state like Michigan
where we voted as a as a state to allow
abortion to continue under Rose
standards it's going to potentially
threaten our ability for a CVS or a
Walgreens or whatever to prescribe the
medication that many many women use
safely prescribed by their doctor it is
deeply disturbing and everyone should be
involved in this if you care about this
issue
what what do you say when you talk to
people who are uh I mean there's a lot
of those we mentioned it in the editor
that there's something like 25 percent
of Democrats are still probe my district
is my life yeah your district is
probably my district is pro-life and
this is how you know the country has
shifted and people are thinking
differently particularly pro-life women
they will pull me aside in an event and
say look I'm pro-life I I'm I'm deeply
Catholic or this is something I feel in
my faith I could never have an abortion
I could never advise my children to have
an abortion but I've never walked in
another woman's shoes and I would never
tell her how to live her life and that
is all we are asking for that is
okay
so the vast majority of Americans
actually can find Common Ground even
outside of their own personal beliefs
it's our dysfunctional political system
that is whipsawing us toward one extreme
or the other on this one it's having
terrible consequences around the country
for women's Reproductive Rights by the
way uh in Israel abortion is paid for by
the government yeah just saying and pay
for it by the government and a religious
State and religious religious state to
religious religious religion believes in
Judaism life begins in first breath
right whether you're into it or not into
religion or not but yeah so in Israel
I'm into breath
uh I get that for it uh what what does
the panel think of YouTube lifting its
ban on Donald Trump oh no yeah
yeah
I mean yeah I mean so
um he's been allowed back on meta and
Twitter and hasn't taken advantage yet
because he's trying to prop up truth
social but I think that's going to
change I think he's going to arrive on
all these platforms and we'll all be
collectively a little bit Dumber for it
well now it's difficult because if
you're a social media platform you're
like wait a minute he's right now the
putative front runner of one of the two
major parties uh so uh you know Banning
him might consist of actually you know
like taking away someone's political
speech and that's that's the bind that
these companies exactly can I just say
that there's a really interesting
Supreme Court case that's being heard
right now that's going to be decided on
whether social media companies can be
held accountable for extreme content
that appears on their sites and it's
actually not about whether Donald Trump
or anyone else gets on Facebook or gets
on anywhere and says these extreme
things it's whether they have designed
algorithms to monetize hate where they
know that that stuff is Click bait they
know that extreme content gets more
views more likes more advertising
dollars so they're monetizing the spread
of extremism that is what the Supreme
Court case is about I don't know which
way they're going to go but I think it's
a super interesting case for the future
of technology who is responsible they
shouldn't be making money off of extreme
content they can't control Donald Trump
but they can control how they make their
money all right we'll have to end it
there I don't want to have CNN late on
their next commercial break thank you
guys we'll see you next week
all right